- Good morning, Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe,
and I believe in people
more than they believe in
themselves, and my sincere
hope is that if you see in
yourself, what I see in you,
you'll be able to change the planet.
So to help you on your
journey, today's message
is execute your idea.
Over to you, Jeff Basos.
(rooster crowing)
(upbeat music)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
- So, it's easy to have ideas.
It's very hard to turn an idea
into a successful product.
There are a lot of steps
in between and it takes
persistence, relentlessness.
So I always tell people who are, you know,
who think they want to be entrepreneurs,
it's, you need a combination of
stubborn relentlessness
and flexibility.
And you have to know when to be which.
And basically, you need to
be stubborn on your vision
because otherwise it will
be too easy to give up.
But, you need to be very
flexible on the details,
because as you go along
pursuing your vision,
you'll find that some of your
preconceptions were wrong.
And you're going to need to be
able to change those things.
So, I think, taking an idea
successfully all the way
to the market, and turning
it into a real product
that people care about
and that really improves
people's lives, is a lot of hard work.
- I love this message.
It's one of my favorite messages.
I 100% agree with Jeff
on this one, and I think
you need to be insanely
stubborn about the mission,
insanely stubborn about the
why you're doing things,
but really flexible about the how.
And I think you need to
have that stubbornness,
especially as an entrepreneur,
because when you're
getting started, you're going
to get so much pushback.
What you create, your product,
your service, won't be
really great at the start,
and so, it will be hard to get
people to buy from you.
You'll have people around you,
friends, family, co-workers,
people in your community
telling you that it's
not going to work out.
You're telling yourself
that sometimes this is crazy
and it's not going to work out.
And so everything around you
is saying that this is crazy,
and that maybe it's not the
smartest thing to do, right?
Being an entrepreneur is
really the smart thing to do.
It might be the best thing
to do, but what we do is
we create a world that does not exist.
The best entrepreneurs
have a vision for a world
that they want to create
that doesn't exist yet.
So, from a practical perspective,
it doesn't make sense.
We're doing something that
has never been done before.
You guys need to be doing
something that's never
been done before, right?
You can model some success,
but at some point you have
to find your own path.
And when you go and create your own path,
that's not practical,
that's not logical because
it doesn't exist yet.
You have to go and create it.
And so you need to have that
stubbornness for the mission,
for the vision, for what end objective
you're trying to create,
because of all the pushback and negativity
and zero progress you're going to make
at the beginning.
If you don't have that stubbornness,
if you aren't willing to say,
"no, this is going to
work out", to yourself and
to the people around
you who are naysayers,
then you're going to quit.
Which most entrepreneurs end up doing.
They quit, they don't
have enough stubbornness
for where they want to go.
The flexibility though,
is about how go out
and accomplish it.
I want to make this world better.
Here is how I want it to look like.
Here's what I want to
change in the industry.
But how you go out and
do it should be flexible.
And this is where, I think,
too many entrepreneurs
are too stubborn.
It has to be this specific
way and this way only.
So you spend all this time
making this perfect plan,
the perfectionist, you want
to make this perfect plan,
and all your time is working on this plan,
and this is exactly how
it's going to play out.
No matter how much planning you do,
it's never going to go
according to that plan.
Every successful business,
look at how they started,
it's not how they started that led them
to their ultimate success.
Sometimes it's a radical
shift in their plan, sometimes
it's a minor shift in their plan.
But it always has to change.
Just look at any company.
Look at how they started,
look at Starbucks.
They started selling just beans.
You couldn't get coffee
going into a Starbucks.
They would only sell you the beans.
BMW started selling airplanes.
It's why their logo is
an airplane propeller.
Wrigley's, the gum company,
started selling other
household products, and
gum was was just used
as a giveaway.
That if you buy X packs
of this other product,
we'll give you some gum.
And they eventually
became the gum company.
It changes so often, and
too many entrepreneurs
are stuck on that it has
to be this specific way.
And if you're not listening
to the market, if you're not
combining what you love
with what the market wants,
you're never going to get to
the success that you're after.
And so that insane
stubbornness for the vision
but total flexibility for
how you accomplish it,
that's what's really
important as an entrepreneur.
If I look at my mission,
what I'm trying to do here,
I want to help a billion entrepreneurs.
I feel I have the potential to do it.
I want to do it because,
on a one on one level
it's just fulfilling to know
that what I do is meaningful,
that I have an impact,
that I wake up daily and
I get to do something that
impacts somebody else's life.
That means something to me.
Seeing your comments come in
every day fills up my soul,
knowing that I put work
out there, and it's being
received well and it's having
an impact on your lives.
That means a lot to me.
On a big scale, I think
entrepreneurs are going to solve
all the problems of the world.
It's not companies, it's not corporations,
it's not government, it's us.
We're going to solve it.
And if I can help a billion
entrepreneurs do something
greater in their companies
to help solve real problems,
that's a major impact I've had.
And so having half a
percent impact on your life,
makes me feel like I'm having
a huge impact on the world.
And that's what I set out to do.
A lot of you guys see me
as YouTuber, and I've said
many times, I'm not addicted to YouTube.
I see YouTube as the best
platform right now, for someone
like me, to spread my
message to someone like you.
So it's the best path for me on my mission
to achieve my big goal.
But that may change.
And I anticipate that it will change.
YouTube will not be the big
player probably in ten years.
So what's the thing that's
going to come along that will
replace YouTube that I have to jump in on,
because I'm going to hit my goal.
I want to have that impact.
And so even the types of
videos, so that's on a macro
of the main strategy.
The main strategy is YouTube,
endbook, and website,
and that will change in the
future, but even the micro
strategy within YouTube, okay,
so YouTube is one of the main
strategies, micro strategy,
Believe Life series,
Top Ten series, Meant to Me series,
Entspresso series, Seven Way series,
those are constantly in flux.
What's working, what's having
an impact, what's helping us
achieve our mission, and which ones are
hurting the channel, or just
stagnating, that we know
that we need to eliminate
and bring something else in.
So not being so attached,
and say, this is a series,
that even if it doesn't
work, I still have to do it.
This is the only series
that's going to work.
If I was like that, then we
wouldn't be having the impact
that we have right now.
It doesn't help me further my mission.
And so I think, too often,
entrepreneurs who start businesses
are not stubborn enough
about where they want to go,
about the mission vision, and
they end up quitting too soon.
And they're too stubborn about
how they go out and execute
their plan, and they're not
open enough to other feedback
to say, hey, I want to help
you get that mission to happen,
here's another way way to
be able to go out and do it.
So the question of the
day today is, I'm curious,
what is something that
you've had to change about
your plan, since getting started.
You went out with this
plan, and you realized that
something didn't work, and
you had to make an adjustment
that then ended up working for you.
What was that change?
What changing your plan, that
little tweak that you made,
how did it work.
I'd love to hear from you
down in the comments below,
and I think it could help the
other entrepreneurs watching
as well.
And, if you leave a comment
within the first couple
hours of this video going live,
you have a chance to win
one of our two daily prizes.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Mike Lamothe from
ChartYourTrade.com.
Mike, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
It really, really means a lot to me, man,
and I hope you enjoyed the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever
Your One Word is, much
love, and I'll see you again
(upbeat music)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
(typing)
- My assistant's got a
great thing now on this.
Once in every four months,
somebody sends an email
saying, "I've got a huge
startup that I want you
to invest in, but you've
got to sign this NDA".
Which literally, every time,
gets an email back that says
(censored) you, right?
And the reason is, I'm a
humongous believer that ideas
are (censored), and that
execution's the game.
We've all got ideas.
Everybody's got ideas.
Do you know how many (censored)
ideas we all have here?
We could probably sit here
for the next two hours,
draw them all out, record
'em, and predict the next 78
great startups over the next nine years.
And?
So, I think the thing
that is another theme
in entrepreneurship is
there is way too much
fodder brought to the idea.
Uber was Magic Cab, three years earlier.
Uber is not an idea.
Uber existed, it's called Magic Cab.
But the guys that execute it, sucked.
So they lost.
So I think, you know, if
there's any level of romance
left in this room about your idea,
I'd like to suffocate it.
Because I think the actual situation is
what you actually do with it.
- I mean the reality is,
reading a book or going
to a conference, or having
a great conversation
where you get this golden
information, that's all fantastic.
But what makes mastery is
execution on the ideas,
not the ideas.
And so no idea works
unless you're willing to
roll up your sleeves, do the
practice, invest the time,
put in the effort, do the work.
I think we've all observed
a lot of people who,
they love reading the
books, they love showing up
at the courses, they do
all the online training,
and nothing ever changes.
And they say, well, you know, I don't know
why it doesn't change, why
my life doesn't change,
why my thinking doesn't
change, why my performance
doesn't change, why my
relationships don't change.
Well, it's because ideas
don't work if you don't
execute on them.
So if you look at the
great business builders,
you look at any great performer,
one thing that makes them great,
is their grit.
One thing that makes them great,
is their hunger to practice.
is their willing to sacrifice.
I mean, yes, they're passionate,
but did you know the root
of the word passion, is suffering.
You've got to be willing
to suffer for your vision.
to suffer to reach
BIW (Best In World).
You've got to be willing to
suffer the ridicule and laughter
of your critics and your
cynics to get to a place
called world-class.
- I mean not a lot of people
know that you are a fantastic
direct response marketer,
with your mail-order business.
Can you talk to us about
that dollar-into-two concept?
- Well, you know, we all pay taxes.
And we all hate the idea
that we're losing that money.
But there's a difference
between hating that you
lose that money, and hating to pay taxes.
I love paying taxes.
If it is the fair amount,
and if it is used wisely,
I think we all have to contribute
it, because it's how you
set up social programs, it's
how you build infrastructure,
it's how you have a military
and all of this kind of thing.
So, that's great, but
I always had the belief
that the money that I pay
in taxes, I want to make up
through wise investments.
So this is why I got into
real estate right away
in the '70's, and I
started buying raw land
and developing that.
I started buying apartment
buildings and you know,
just think about it, I remember
in 1974 I bought my first
apartment building,
and we bought it for $215,000,
that was then a lot of money.
- Yeah
- And I put only down
like maybe $35 - $37,000,
but within two years, the
apartment building was worth,
instead of the $215,
$350,000, and I sold it.
So imagine now how much gain there was.
- (Interviewer) Yeah
- I mean, so we made hundreds
of percent on my initial
investment, so that's
what I'm talking about.
See it takes thoughts and
ideas can make much more money
than actual physical labor.
- Um hm
- And physical labor is always
part of the action because
I always say you've got to
work your ass off no matter
what you do, because now you
have a great idea, but then
you still have to implement
it, and you have to hassle,
you have to go the bank, get
their financial statement,
do this and that, and raise
money sometimes, and you go
to look at a thousand
apartment buildings to find
the right one and all
of these kind of things.
So you still have to work.
But normally if it's just
physical labor, you can never
make the money that you can
make when you have ideas.
This is where it's important,
I always tell people, I say,
"the secret is, there are
certain times, don't think."
Like when you get up in
the morning, don't think.
Just roll out of bed, go
on your Lifecycle, or go on
a bicycle ride, or go to
the gym, workout, you know
that's what you have to do.
And then read something
and learn something.
So don't even thing about it.
- Yeah
- But there's other times
when you have to really think
and you really have to get
creative and have a clear vision
of where you want to go
and what you want to do.
And that's what I always had,
and that's what I always believed in.
I always believed in making
money so that then you can
do something with that.
You invest in it in orders,
eventually you create a family,
you give some of it to your
kids and all that stuff.
But also for charity.
Look, I have the Schwarzenegger
Institute at USC.
- (Interviewer) Yeah
- So we have to raise money
all the time and big money
to pay for that and to support that.
We have the R20, the
environmental organization,
or any organization of any idea's great,
but if you don't have the money,
you can't implement anything.
And so, this is why it is
important that if it is
an environmental organization
or if it is my afterschool
programs, that are nationwide,
where we raise millions
and millions of dollars every year.
Or if it just, you know,
living in a great mansion
or driving a nice Bentley in the Bulgari.
You know, this, the kind of
things, it takes money to do all
of this kind of stuff.
So therefore, I believe in
making one dollar into two,
and having a good time
when I pay my taxes.
(laughs)
- So when someone says,
"yes, yes, Arnold, I
say, we have bad news".
"You owe 50 million dollars in taxes".
I say, "wow, yes!"
And then they look at me and says,
"why are you happy about that?"
- (Interviewer) He's finally lost it.
- Because that means you must
have made a lot of money.
You have to pay that much money in taxes.
And they say, "yeah, that's
a way to look at it".
So that's the way I look at it.